quoi c'est parti merci bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est en danger dans le champ vallon
il m'a dit non oui je joue au ballon
[Musique]
hamon
programme
[Musique]
je vais toujours de la merde
b
je sans toi
aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout qu'ils
soient prêts au bail va attendre deux
minutes ils m'ont dit sont prêts à sky
les eaux
je sais toi
aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais je suis très bon pour les danseurs
c'est ça son marabout
j'adore c'est un vrai bonheur ou vraie
surprise qu'a miquel alma famille ces
gars là d'un vrai cadeau bravo camille
bravo à tous bravo les furious est dans
meetic le titre est exceptionnel merci
merci mais vraiment je vous le disais
même si je n'ai que je pense que cela
évoque trois coups rigoles ou quoi
on en est où sacha alors on est au
attention là le mec je suis motivé gâte
pour voir vert actif comme ça là et on
sait on prend beaucoup de risques l'art
pour ton juste pour diffuser un titre
bidonvilles alors quel champ mais alors
je vais demander à aymeric qui présente
la tranche du 16 20 de nous diffuser le
titre bidonvilles tout ça craint peu
d'ambiance sur skyrock com vient tout de
suite tout de suite à diaboliser allant
là où cyril quand vous m'envoyer en
mission est ce que est ce que quand vous
envoyer en mission moi j'ai l'habitude
de rater mes missions
oui mais non et ben non je dis non je
vous inscrire c'est une mission halal à
papa du petit amsellem frère c'est tout
ce que tu as fait elle alors dis-moi qui
s'étaient noyés bric à brac faut pas
faire et on va faire une rapide mitzvah
chez skyrock
regardez salut aymeric merci de nous
recevoir d'un amour et oryx est il qu'en
basse sur skyrock quoi il passe en ce
moment à aymeric aymeric alors on est en
direct sur skyrock et l'âge et la clé
usb
j'ai la clé usb dis moi tu viendras
passé enrique est ce que tu veux les
outils de gad elmaleh dans trente
secondes je passe en dentelle je passais
ventes au canada et dans toute la france
ouais c'est énorme s'est mal passé c'est
magnifique
attention il va lancer quand il valoir
on est en direct sur skyrock je vous
jure 86eme partir également regarder tes
pmb en font elles vous pouvez faire les
deux pour la première fois mais tu étais
pnb pascal gad elmaleh le poteau qui a
invité et vous savez quoi
on va diffuser saluer ce que les autres
leaders de ce cas là on a un oeil à dj
abdel magnifique sur le titre c'est le
petit galli temps de vider le morceau
s'appelle bidonvilles avec le mans ces
champs mais et bons voeux diffusés sur
skyrock sur le premier à dire deux
mandats c'est énorme mais c'est
magnifique
j'ai attaqué c'est psioniques un amour
de mec merci tous les gentils américains
qui font ça y est c'est parti c'est sur
skyrock
là où tu es sur skyrock ferait bondir la
mecque a même offert maison ce jour
sur skyrock ok ce qui me reste encore
nrj jean lacroix ira pas tu sais ce
qu'on avait réuni dsk et moi
là on est bon on est bons l'albertaine
non en arca c'est pas mal tu vertes et
non pas qu'ils appellent tous ceux qui
veulent ouvrir votre porte et là on est
bien on est bien j'appelle régis ravanas
c'est le grand patron jean noël à [ __ ]
on est bien ce que j'appelle des gens
aujourd'hui [ __ ] ait des gens qui
n'avaient jamais fait mais je sais qu'on
n'a pas terminé le titre tout à l'heure
un ovale terminée et les beats audio 8
heures maintenant mes choix du buteur
cette qualité en tête jusqu'à 4 heures
du matin à ces quatre là c'était moi je
veux que j'appelle à tel ou pas vas-y
que la peine ces grands patrons tension
judicieux avec toi rtl rtl soir cadel
manille j'appelle tu as fait tout le
monde j'en ai la foudre je peux enfin ap
un regard on a tout enlevé du plateau
nous ont tout enlever les huissiers sont
passées à regarder son passé sont tous
pris auprès ils ont pris tout il reste
plus rien dans l'art et la poutre l uni
terminée voilà qu'est ce qu'il nous
reste à
régis way régis comment ça va c'est
cyril hanouna savamment régissant bras
ce pour moi alors je suis avec gad
elmaleh on en direct il me disait qu'il
aimait beaucoup
ouais bah voila tu vois ce qui est un
amour que j'aime beaucoup c'est le
président d'rtl registre et que gad un
nouveau titre une reprise de claude
nougaro exceptionnel bidonvilles qu'elle
cette chanson
régis il faut lire entre le mois sur rtl
on supplie une fois ou deux dans un bail
comme ça q qu'est ce que tu veux
j'arrive de soi c'est quoi ta taille à
ckoi taillon banon table de ping pong
je pense que tu veux relief une fois que
nommé ces parias pas ok on joue à sucre
chez les rats de frein au processus et
que je t'aime et je t'aime encore plus
sega devait être comme un fou donc si tu
aurais tu rentres tout de même une fois
écoute le titre qu'il faut pas si c'est
une fois c'est pas la peine immense
avoir évincé comment ça va résiste à une
ré histoire l'agression il me suis super
spectacle étonnant c'est compris que tu
fais dans la main il me faut ce thème en
tout cas c'est en tout cas merci passé
le titre ça me touche énormément que tu
t'engages vraiment en direct devant la
france entière a passé le titre
j'invite tous les auditeurs d'rtl si le
titre ne passe pas le réclamer ce sera
simplement un oubli de régis dé régis va
s'engager merci infiniment parce que dix
rotations par heure je trouve que c'est
un dérapage qui est énorme on applaudit
régis ravanas est bouclé
[Applaudissements]
joaillière si régis ont tous fait des
gros bisous créons nevers t elle je
t'embrasse est en bois trouvés distant
mois de fort